gen Z especially their number one search
engine is Tick Tock people are getting
paid as regular salary from a brand to
create content people don't really
realize the power of how many companies
are searching Tick Tock for a Creator
and it's not always about this person
has the biggest following it's about
does this person look good on camera
does this person have a clean enough
brand but we can have them represent our
companies
so what are the best practices this year
for growing your business using Tick
Tock I'm super excited because in this
episode of the think media podcast Kenya
Kelly is back on the show dropping some
Advanced tips that I'm certain you
haven't heard anywhere else and some new
things that you need to know when it
comes to getting reach on Tick Tock some
of the new features and some cool ways
to monetize so Kenya how's it going it's
going good I'm Still Loving Tick Tock
and it's still my favorite thing to do
yeah I love it and it's one of uh of
course on our community we talk a lot
about YouTube but with YouTube shorts
and the chance to do vertical video our
Tick Tock official think media has been
blowing up just as we've repurposed con
yet and so I'm excited to learn all of
these details from you in today's
episode and so you were sharing speaking
here yesterday at Social Media Marketing
World on some Advanced strategies for
success on Tick Tock we'll go through a
couple of them yeah but what's new at
Tick Tock first there's a couple new
things like you can now download the
video without the watermark yeah so it's
a brand new feature most accounts don't
have it yet but they're updating it but
you're able to once you have a video in
drafts and you pull it up on your main
screen and the upper right hand corner
you're going to see a little download
button and that means you just hit that
and now you've downloaded your video
without the watermark no more screen
recording no more other apps and
directly from Tick Tock yeah that's
powerful and of course in some cases
creators will use this separate website
to pull that yeah yeah but this is kind
of like Instagram reels that allows you
to build out The Tick Tock essentially
yeah and then ease more easily repurpose
it elsewhere yes for sure maybe not
embed the music yet uh yes exactly
before that for sure therefore then you
could connect the music yeah definitely
on reels or somewhere else and shorts
and Facebook reels now yeah so that
because if best practice would be on
every platform yeah connecting the
native popular music correct time you
upload it exactly yeah so that's a super
cool feature and also this this one blew
my mind gen Z especially their number
one search engine is Tick Tock oh yes so
people think Google AI chat gbt might
redo search but in the meantime like all
generations but especially younger
Generations go to tick tock searching
for things yes so Tick Tock SEO is a
real thing indexing videos longer
captions what's what are some of these
new updates yeah so it used to be where
you could only have 300 uh characters in
your descriptions now it's 2200 but it's
not about you creating these very long
descriptions but it's more so about you
being very intentional about your
keywords for example let's just say
you're teaching YouTube right but your
video is about
um creating a YouTube short well what
Tick Tock wants you to do now is they
want you to be very intentional about
your SEO keywords so instead of you just
saying YouTube shorts or whatever you
would say how to create a video on
YouTube shorts and when you do that and
then you start writing just a few little
keywords in the captions if you do your
SEO correctly Tick Tock is now like
you're gonna see above your video a
little search box and you're not going
to search there but you will see how you
did a good job with SEO because it will
say how to create a YouTube short up top
and that lets you know that your video
is trending in that particular category
when someone goes to search for how to
create a YouTube short or if you're
saying to yourself how do I make a key
lime pie and if you want someone making
key lime pies and you're saying it on
screen like you're saying like you're
literally saying here's how to create a
key lime pie and then you have the
correct things that SEO in your
descriptions your video is going to be
the first one they see when they search
how to create a key lime pie got it and
so especially for maybe like a local
service provider yeah they could start
thinking about properly doing the
metadata around their video so that they
could be found in real estate or local
region and you how did you noticed your
videos are indexing exactly what you
said you see that it's tick tock for
business or something and then it starts
showing up yep so I have one of my
videos trending right now is how to use
tick tock promote and I have a course in
my description how to use tick tock
remote and what I've noticed is that on
that video I see above the video where
Tick Tock has put up there how to use
tick tock remote and then when I go to
the main search screen and just type in
how to use 6. promote I'm one of the top
videos that then comes up in the you
know in all the viral videos you know
it's in our community too we have a
course called video ranking Academy and
we're just obsessed with the of course
uh suggested opportunity of kind of
going viral on YouTube but also just the
Practical opportunity of search based
content yeah and how to is one of the
best ways to start videos how to fill in
what you teach how to uh compare you
know a couple different you know so
using how to is a major strategy yeah on
YouTube this is now relevant take Totten
yeah powerful now a couple other things
that you shared about one was Tick Tock
live shopping what's that yeah so is in
beta form but basically where it's like
um it's kind of the Home Shopping
Network QVC where a brand that is a
product based business they have access
to where two things one when they post
content let's just say this whole outfit
and I want to advertise this Cami or
whatever I have on well I am able to put
in like my inventory of products in in
Tick Tock and then people are able to
purchase whatever items I have in my
particular video but also you're able to
do Tick Tock live streams with your
inventory or products there as well and
people never have to leave The Tick Tock
app to make a purchase and so it's in
tick tock's best interest of one how do
we keep people on the platform two how
do we help businesses make money and if
I'm able to buy this shirt without ever
leaving Tick Tock it's it's golden for
me for tick tock and the person that's
making the that's making the sales wow
and then another thing you shared about
was some opportunities in influencer
marketing what's happening there so ugc
which is user generated content has
exploded in 2022 and then now more so in
2023 where not only us as creators but a
brand will come to us and ask us to
create 15 second video one or two but
now it's become this like hey create 10
videos a month and people are getting
paid like this regular salary from a
brand to create content and so a lot of
times Brands don't want to create
content on Tick Tock yet because they
don't have an in-house person to create
vertical video like to be on face but
they're able to hire a Creator and the
creator doesn't have to go to work they
just have to to create content for this
particular brand and they're making
thousands of thousands of dollars
through creating content but as a
business you're able to take this
content creator who's already good on
camera looks good on camera knows how to
edit and create these fun videos for
your brand and you're able to take that
piece run it as ads put it on Tick Tock
and all the different vertical video
platforms and they're able to explode
that way are you ready to start or grow
your YouTube channel do you feel stuck
and need help connecting the dots join
this free web class where you'll learn
the step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com so this
is a big opportunity so to break this
down for our community user generated
content is content that maybe is being
made anyways people are talking about
your brand if you have some kind of a
product and especially for those maybe
you are in e-commerce or thinking about
launching a product besides thinking you
have to build your own influence what
you're saying is that because you know
how to create content because you learn
how to create vertical videos brands
that have products are now looking to
get content creators to make them UPC to
make them product tutorials yep and then
they're paying them and they may be
posting those on their own account
correct but then they also would go on
the brands account yes so we have a lot
we actually have an interesting number
of of kind of tool channels people that
do like DeWalt tools and all kinds of
different tools and so it may be
something like that like maybe even
DeWalt as big of a company as they are
they don't have a face or somebody
correct but they have people that are
working for them so how are these deals
coming about how if somebody was like
man I would love the opportunity I know
I can make videos I can be creative and
I can be fun and my own platforms are
not very big yet how are they getting in
touch with these Brands to make ugc for
them in a paid fashion yeah so the
number one way is by creating content on
Tick Tock people don't really realize
the power of how many companies are sir
urging take Toc for a Creator they don't
really it's like it's thousands and
thousands of people every day looking
for creators on the platform and mostly
it's not necessarily Nike it's the
agency that does marketing for uh for
Nike so they have this person who they
are searching looking for a man or a
woman or whatever or uh whatever they're
looking for and it's this Creator who
they're they're seeing the and it's not
always about this person has the biggest
following it's about does this person
look good on camera does this person
have a clean enough brand but we can
have them represent our company so first
creating content on Tick Tock but the
second most powerful way is having your
profile in these influencer marketing
agencies database so there's thousands
of companies that do influence of
marketing and me on a regular basis I do
couple things one I'm always on Google
typing in influencer marketing agencies
and if a new one pops up I go to their
website I click on influencer and I just
set up a set up a profile where it's me
it's my account it's what I do yada yada
yada and then it's in there and what
ends up happening is that this agency
then has this company that wants to work
with them and they are looking for a
person like me and they're able to do a
like a filter search in their database
they find me and then they contact me so
like it's work of like finding all these
agencies and putting up your profile but
I've made almost 150 000 doing it that
way just having my profile set up wow
that's powerful strategy and uh next up
is people ask the question what type of
content should I create on Tick Tock and
what are some of the opportunities there
so I say three things one is micro
learning and it's basically where micro
learning is giving people one piece of
advice or a tip or what have you versus
everything like I'm a business coach and
so I could talk about that for hours and
hours and hours but people don't have
hours to spend to listen to me so I just
take one topic and I talk about it for
about 45 seconds that's called micro
learning where people are able to take
one thing learn one thing and say wow
that was really good I can apply that to
ABC whatever and then now they want to
watch the next thing and the next thing
tank the second thing is I call it what
I say a product teasers and I had this
you know a scenario about what's
happening with Chipotle and basically
um this is where like you have this
particular product and you're not
necessarily saying they're not
necessarily saying go and buy this thing
you're just showcasing it so like this
one brand I have a skin care and they're
always showing these girls just showing
their skincare routine they never say go
buy this that's this but now you want
this strawberry thing that's going to
make my skin look like x y z but like
with Chipotle they had there's a Creator
name is Keith Lee everybody on Tick Tock
loves Keith Lee and Keith um is a food
reviewer he's just in Vegas he just
removes reviews food and what happened
was like somebody on Tick Tock was
talking about how they go to Chipotle
they get a quesadilla but they put steak
in it and they put fajitas in it and
Keith always goes places comes on and
says imma try it and I'm gonna rate it
one through ten he always does that and
so he's on screen and he is trying this
quesadilla we don't know how good it is
and we know when it's good because Keith
does this like
like a past three and he and he just
keeps eating and he tells everybody to
go to Chipotle and get this thing so it
explodes for Chipotle they're like what
is going on and so they contact Keith
Lee and the girl he learned about it
from and then there is a product teaser
video with him and his car with the girl
and they're saying hey Chipotle is
changing their menu it's coming in March
they don't say go buy it and just say
it's coming so millions of people when
that thing lost on the app went to
Chipotle and chipotle didn't have a
commercial about it it was Tick Tock wow
that's powerful it speaks to the
influence and speaks to taking something
you're passionate about and being
creative and trying food and what it can
lead to if you punch fear in the face
and get out there and start creating
content and so
um that is amazing as we land the plane
if someone's thinking they see what
you're doing they look around there's a
lot of people crushing it and and one
nugget that's interesting that's kind of
happening in this moment is we're
talking we just talked about this off
camera we're here at Social Media
Marketing world and and I've been many
people that have been coming on the show
have just gotten started since 2020. of
course that was the pandemic and it
reminds me of a study from Adobe that's
had 165 million people joined the crater
economy since 2020. it was such a
disruptive event people were locked down
some people just started making content
but what was why I'll do was see the
maturity of it now in 2023 that we're
talking about people who you know quit
their corporate job and went full time
in 10 months but I know that sometimes
that could be discouraging because
someone's like well I've been going two
years and I still well there's different
different paces and different niches and
different topics and nevertheless it's
been shocking how many people I've met
here that have just got in the game not
10 years ago not five years ago but
literally just in the last few years so
it's not too late to start but I'm
curious for you you coach so many
different people that I I'm sure they
have all kinds of imposter syndrome
negative self-talk it's really easy to
talk yourself out of pressing record
yeah is it even worth starting and so
what advice would you give somebody
that's starting this year so the first
thing I would ask tell a person is to
ask yourself why why do you have fear
around it right because no matter what
we say you're still going to get on
camera until you know why you have fear
around it uh but once you know you
identify what that is then what you also
want to ask yourself is what is what
would be your goal like is it because
you want to just you want to quit your
job it's because you really want to be
an influencer or you really want to
start this business and then once you
kind of know like what the fear is and
what you want to do then I would advise
you to then like I always tell my
clients just start recording content and
don't hit post initially just get
comfortable like just standing there
with this phone in your face do a
vertical video of just recording and
then just doing it and doing it and
doing it then I always tell a person to
send it to a trusted friend who loves
you who can give you feedback who can
also encourage you but then also just
like it's kind of like fomo take a look
at somebody who you saw when they first
got started and like here's where you
are right now and like then tell
yourself what if I would have started
back then okay there was that but what
if I start right now what could happen
for me if I like go I'm just gonna hit a
post on this and I'm gonna keep doing
this even though I feel fear even though
how like how I look or sound on camera
but I'm looking at look at them and I
can do it too you know it's gonna take a
lot of Courage you're gonna feel cringy
you're gonna do all the like things
about yourself but every single person
that first started never said that they
were awesome I'm great on camera no one
felt that way yeah that's such great
advice and uh thank you so much for
sharing your wisdom today can you if
people want to connect with you wear you
out shout out your stuff and what are
you working on right now yeah so I am on
Kia kelly.com I'm King Kelly on Tick
Tock and Instagram the number one thing
we are focused on right now is managing
accounts on Tick Tock so like for three
years people have asked us to manage
their accounts and so now we're not
offering that service and you can find
all that on kenkelly.com awesome we'll
link it up in the show notes thanks for
being a part of this episode of the
think media podcast